[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le jeudi 26 janvier voici le programme
de ce soir son incendie au mois de
novembre 2019 avait suscité une vive
émotion trois ans après le chapiteau de
Chanteloup-les-Vignes René de ses
cendres ce soir son nom est tout trouvé
le phénix il se trouve au même
emplacement que l'ancien équipement
culturel mais sans distingue sur de
nombreux aspects c'est devenu la scène
la mieux équipée du département tout au
long du mois de janvier période
traditionnelle des vœux tv78 reçoit des
maires de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines pour
parler des grands projets de l'année
2023 dans leur ville ce soir focus sur
Villepreux inflation nouveau pôle
sportif Maison des Arts quels sont les
grands projets de l'année 2023 dans la
commune le maire Jean-Baptiste à Monique
est notre invité nous suivrons également
sur le terrain notre journaliste Nicolas
dandry qui se trouve au vœu de
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines et
puis comme d'habitude le jeudi à
l'approche du week-end nous vous
donnerons nos idées de sortie dans les
Yvelines nous parlerons notamment de la
Thoiry night race une course nocturne au
cœur du zoo de Thoiry ce sera avec notre
invité Anthony Marie et pour les plus
gourmands nous partirons aussi à la
découverte du restaurant Le petit
bouillon de Versailles sans oublier les
idées de sortie de notre journaliste
Gabriel Gonthier bonsoir bonsoir
Mathilde alors qu'est-ce que vous nous
avez prévu pour ce soir et moi ce soir
on parlera notamment d'un concert de
rock un concert de rock proposé par le
groupe Legacy 7.0 se concert qui a lieu
à Montigny-le-Bretonneux et c'est
vendredi soir et donc ce sera tout à
l'heure on va revenir aussi sur une date
célèbre c'était la semaine dernière le
lycée franco-allemand de Bux célébré les
60 ans du traité de l'Élysée alors pour
rappel le traité de l'Elysée c'est le
pacte qui avait pour but de réconcilier
la France avec l'Allemagne après
plusieurs décennies de conflits l'idée
était aussi de construire un bloc
européen solide face aux Etats-Unis et à
l'URSS dans un contexte de guerre froide
pour en parler avec nous marier Alix
Morlaix bonsoir bonsoir merci de
m'accueillir vous êtes la proviseur du
lycée franco-allemand de Buc alors
pourquoi est-ce que c'est important 60
ans après de célébrer ce traité de
l'Elysée alors comme vous l'avez laissé
entendre le traité de l'Elysée fait
partie de notre histoire de notre
essence et de notre quotidien donc c'est
se 60e anniversaire répond non seulement
à ce devoir de mémoire à la construction
citoyenne de nos élèves mais aussi à un
temps fort qui permet de faire vivre
l'établissement et le sentiment
d'appartenance et donc on en parlera
plus en détail tout à l'heure dans cette
émission nous parlerons également de la
nuit des conservatoires elle aura lieu
demain soir et le Conservatoire
conservatoire de Maurepas y participe
Julien Pauly bonsoir vous êtes le
directeur du conservatoire demeure pas
alors quel est le programme de demain
soir alors c'est toute une soirée
musicale et théâtrale qui va se dérouler
de 18h à minuit à peu près avec
plusieurs propositions artistiques pour
tout public voilà gratuitement sur le
site du conservatoire et de l'espace
Albert Camus donc pareil on en parlera
plus en détail tout à l'heure mais avant
je tends un petit coup d'œil à la météo
de demain
demain matin le ciel sera nuageux sur
l'ensemble du département au niveau des
températures il fera froid compter 4
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie 3 à Houdan et
Versailles et deux à Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi le ciel sera toujours
couvert au niveau des températures
comptez 3 à 2 degrés en moyenne et
demain nous fêterons la sainte Angèle
comme la chanteuse le point maintenant
sur l'actualité dans les Yvelines
et c'est avec vous c'est une charge
bonsoir bonsoir Mathilde on commence par
l'image du jour j'en parlais à l'instant
c'est le nouveau chapiteau de
Chanteloup-les-Vignes oui évidemment
Mathilde le chapiteau de
Chanteloup-les-Vignes René enfin de ses
cendres souvenez-vous en novembre 2019
ce lieu qui a accueillait à une
compagnie de théâtre à destination
d'enfants et de jeunes du quartier de la
Noé avait été incendie au terme d'une
nuit d'affrontement entre jeunes et
forces de l'ordre un incendie qui avait
suscité comme vous l'avez dit une vive
émotion bien au-delà de la ville avec
après plus de 3 ans le chapiteau rouvre
ses portes au public aujourd'hui et sous
un nouveau nom le phénix le cirque
devient maintenant un centre artistique
et numérique il se destinent au
spectacle vivant concert théâtre cinéma
danse et aux événements festifs on
poursuit avec notre chiffre du jour
c'est 2,5 millions pourquoi parce que
Mathilde a 547 jours des Jeux Olympiques
Paris 2024 2,5 millions de personnes se
sont déjà inscrites pour obtenir des
tickets sur la billetterie en ligne une
première phase qui va déboucher sur
l'attribution des créneaux d'achat en
février alors attention si vous comptez
vous inscrire dépêchez-vous vous n'avez
que jusqu'au 31 janvier pour le faire et
c'est dans ce contexte que le président
Paris 2024 Tony estanguay a présenté ses
vœux lors d'une conférence de rentrée
parmi les annonces dans les Yvelines des
épreuves tests vont être mises en place
il y aura une épreuve directement
organisée par Paris 2024 il s'agit d'une
compétition de VTT le 24 septembre sur
la colline d'Élancourt et un test
opérationnel organisé par le comité un
concours complet d'équitation le 19
septembre au château de Versailles sport
encore mais football cette fois-ci le FC
Versailles jouera son premier match de
l'année 2023 à domicile ce week-end
l'équipe reçoit le Puy foot 43 pour le
compte de la 19e journée de Nationale 1
les Versailles leaders seront les
favoris de la rencontre face à des
Auvergnats qui occupent actuellement la
16e place du championnat le match se
déroulera au stade Jean Bouin à Paris
l'entrée est gratuite pour les moins de
18 ans et il y a du nouveau concernant
la succession de Catherine pegard à la
tête du château de Versailles en effet
pour rappel le dernier mandat de
Catherine pegard président du château de
Versailles depuis 2011 c'est
officiellement terminé en octobre 2022
mais le choix de sa succession qui
revient au président de la République
Emmanuel Macron se fait encore attendre
les Lisa avait soumis au Conseil d'État
au début janvier un projet de décret
permettant à Catherine pegard de
continuer à présider le château une
tentative qui avait été retoquée mais
cette semaine en amendement à la loi sur
les jeux olympiques 2024 a été déposé le
stipule je cite que les personnes
exerçant des fonctions de président ou
de directeur d'établissements publics à
la date de l'attribution des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de 2024 à
Paris et qui participe directement à
l'organisation de ces jeux peuvent
nonobstant toute disposition contraire
exercer l'édit de fonction jusqu'au 31
décembre 2024 un amendement qui s'il est
voté voté pourrait permettre à la
présidente de garder ses fonctions le
château accueillant les épreuves
d'équitation à Versailles pour Paris
2024 et on termine ces informations par
la mobilisation sociale final contre la
réforme des retraites qui se poursuit ce
jeudi 26 avant la Journée Nationale du
31 plusieurs secteurs ont appelé à la
grève notamment les raffineries les
expéditions de carburant devraient être
bloqués aujourd'hui et demain vers les
dépôts alors malgré tout les stations
services devraient rester
approvisionnées durant ces deux jours de
nombreux outils en ligne sont à votre
disposition pour connaître en temps réel
la situation de votre station d'essence
et bien si on est en manque d'essence on
va aller bientôt faire le plein je pense
merci beaucoup Céline Charles pour ces
informations du jour et si vous aussi
comme d'habitude vous voyez une
information qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager en utilisant le hashtag 7 8
news
ce soir Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
célèbre ses vœux pour l'année 2023
c'était au Vélodrome national de Sky à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux le président de
l'agglomération Jean-Michel fourgousse
va tenir un discours environ 1500
personnes sont attendues ce soir et nous
retrouvons sur le terrain Nicolas dandry
alors Nicolas comment ça va se passer ce
soir
et bien écoutez les invités pour ces
vœux de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour
arriver aux alentours de 19h et puis le
discours de Jean-Michel furbus
va commencer à partir de 20h il te
l'inverse son discours vous le voyez
derrière moi la tribu et puis là vous
entendez raisonner la Marseillaise parce
qu'effectivement la Marseillaise sera
forcément déjà retenti cette année ici
notamment pendant les championnats du
monde de cyclisme sur piste au Vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
une Mercedes qu'on a pu entendre
notamment lorsque Mathilde gros a été
championne du monde de cyclisme sur
piste et bien forcément il en sera
question puisque
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines est une terre
de jeux olympiques et nous sommes à un
an des Jeux Olympiques avec l'impatience
je sais que certains 5 continents et 56
mois sont impatientes d'accueillir ces
Jeux Olympiques vous le savez Vélodrome
national un des sites olympiques il y
aura aussi la piste de BMX qui aura les
épreuves de VTT sur la colline de la
revanche et puis il y aura les
compétitions de golf au golf nationale
voilà c'est l'un des sujets qui sera
abordé ce soir dans le discours de
Jean-Michel fourousse la sobriété
énergétique sera également au programme
Nicolas on en entend parler partout
oui effectivement la sobriété
énergétique 50 ans en place un plan de
sobriété dans l'ensemble des 12 communes
et puis vous le savez 50 ans en Yvelines
études terre économique et il y a de
grandes entreprises qui sont présentes
sur le territoire Jean-Michel porros
devrait rendre hommage aussi assez
grands groupes qui qui font la splendeur
du territoire on pense notamment à
Airbus dans le cadre de l'activité
aéronautique on pense aussi à Thalès
dans la cybersécurité et puis il y a
aussi les PME les TPE et les startups
qui font et bien la richesse et qui font
l'économie de ces territoires vous savez
que l'économie est un sujet qui tient à
cœur à Jean-Michel fourmousse et grâce
aux politiques différentes politiques
mises en place par
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et bien ça
rend attractif le territoire pour ces
entreprises et bien merci beaucoup
Nicolas dandry pour toutes ces
précisions et merci également à Mickaël
el midoro aux moyens techniques et il
n'y en a pas il n'y a pas qu'à
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin
président le dira tout à l'heure
j'imagine lors de ces vœux au 50-îois on
a engagé un grand plan de sobriété c'est
aussi ce que nous avons fait à
Villepreux je pense que la sobriété
c'est pas quelque chose de nouveau il
faut pas faire croire je pense à nos
administrer à nos concitoyens qu'on se
réveille tardivement sur tous ces enjeux
de transition écologique énergétique
évidemment on était déjà dans une
culture de l'optimisation puisque pour
moi la sobriété elle est sur deux plans
il y a la sobriété énergétique
écologique environnementale et la
sobriété budgétaire et finalement les
deux sont liés donc oui que ce soit sur
l'éclairage et à Villepreux on était
déjà assez performant en la matière
depuis quelques années maintenant que ce
soit sur la réduction des périodes de
chauffe sur les températures aussi où on
a baissé on a suivi les recommandations
du gouvernement et de l'État à un
certain nombre de degrés notamment dans
les classes aussi dans les équipements
sportifs donc c'est plein de petits
efforts comme ça qui me bout à bout ne
sont pas uniquement des économies de
bout de chandelle mais des vrais je dis
pas qu'ils peuvent permettre de faire la
différence en tout cas aujourd'hui pour
nous c'était une nécessité c'est de
sobriété est une nécessité puisqu'on est
devant une situation budgétaire
éminemment complexe je regardais ça en
début de semaine avec mon directeur
financier en deux ans on a quand même
perdu l'équivalent d'un million d'euros
d'épargne et justement cette épargne
c'est ce qui nous permet demain de
réinvestir dans l'avenir et notamment de
réinvestir dans nos bâtiments qui ont
cruellement besoin de travaux de
rénovation énergétique justement vous
êtes inquiet concernant les comptes les
finances de votre ville oui je suis
inquiet et ça nous a d'ailleurs amené à
faire des choix je crois que 2023 c'est
vraiment l'année des choix on peut même
parler de sacrifices sur sur certains
aspects puisque c'est jamais facile de
dire que on va pas pouvoir tenir la
saison théâtrale puisque c'est un
équipement vieillissant qu'on n'arrivera
pas à chauffer sans engendrerait de de
trop fort coup c'est pas facile de dire
que la piscine municipale qui est
ouverte l'été ne on va pouvoir ouvrir
cette année mais c'est des choix que
nous faisons pour maintenir les services
publics on va dire vitaux de première
nécessité et pour nous il y a évidemment
une priorité c'est l'accompagnement et
le soutien des familles et derrière ça
je mets évidemment l'éducation je mets
la politique évidemment dans nos écoles
je pense aussi aux solidarités avec tout
le soutien qu'on peut avoir sur les
personnes les plus fragiles sur nos
seniors sur les familles monoparentales
sur toute celles et ceux qui sont en
recherche aussi d'un logement et puis
l'accompagnement aussi de la vie
associative qui nous paraît qui nous
paraît important donc c'est vrai que
c'est assez compliqué aujourd'hui on
cumule plusieurs choses on cumule
l'impact de la crise covid l'inflation
généralisée avec la hausse des tarifs de
l'énergie ça va avoir de fortes
répercussions on est à plus de 80%
d'augmentation sur Villepreux sur 2023
par rapport à 2022 des côtes de
l'énergie et mise tout ça ni bout à bout
avec évidemment des dotations globales
de fonctionnement qui qui diminuent le
mécanisme de pairaquation qui pour la
faire très courte et pas rentrer dans
des aspects techniques
original finalement pardon le mécanisme
qui impose aux communes qui ont une
bonne gestion de contribuer davantage
pour celles qui sont un peu plus en
nécessité d'avoir des subsides alors je
suis pour ce mécanisme de solidarité
mais c'est vrai que tout ça mis bout à
bout ça fait que c'est assez compliqué
pour nous de nous retrouver dans une
situation financière favorable mais on
demeure optimiste et on a des beaux
projets néanmoins pour Villepreux alors
on va parler des beaux projets vous avez
parlé dans vos priorités de l'éducation
par quoi est-ce que ça va passer
concrètement qu'est-ce que vous allez
mettre en place alors je m'attarderai
pas ce soir sur le projet éducatif de
territoire qui évidemment pour nous le
cadre qui nous permet de mener une
politique éducative avec l'ensemble de
nos partenaires sur la commune de
Villepreux là je il y a deux sujets
finalement ce sont nos deux priorités je
pense que nous allons pouvoir relier
l'éducation les écoles et la transition
énergétique puisque j'aimerais qu'on
arrive à bâtir dans les prochains mois
un plan de rénovation ou en tout cas de
réhabilitation de nos écoles dont
certaines sont assez vieillissantes et
je crois que si on veut justement
parvenir à être performant sur cet
aspect écologique et environnemental il
faut qu'on puisse engager des travaux et
c'est tout le sujet notamment d'un audit
que nous avons porté dès le début du
mandat on a décidé en 2020 d'audité la
cinquantaine de bâtiments publics
municipaux que nous avons sur le
territoire communal pour dégager des
grandes priorités d'investissement parce
qu'on parlait du contexte budgétaire ça
nous impose et c'est ce qu'on fait déjà
et c'est déjà ce que faisait mes
prédécesseurs à Villepreux à une rigueur
à une responsabilité budgétaire à faire
des économies à optimiser sur les
dépenses de fonctionnement mais on a
quand même besoin d'investir dans
l'avenir puisqu'on est une commune qui
se rajeunit on a une commune qui évolue
il y a évidemment des nouveaux habitants
qui arrivent il y a ceux qui sont là qui
méritent d'avoir des services publics de
qualité et donc oui pour l'éducation
pour l'école en tout cas pour les écoles
je pense que avec des dispositifs comme
le faux vert du gouvernement comme les
différents projets et dispositifs de nos
partenaires financiers peuvent être la
région avec département j'ose espérer
qu'on arrive à engager les premiers
travaux de réhabilitation énergétique
alors dans votre discours de vœux pour
2023 vous parlez notamment du pôle
sportif du vpark alors c'est son
ouverture est prévue en septembre 2023
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
quelques mots l'appareil c'est dans
cette idée d'avoir une ville attractive
qui aussi répond aux besoins des
associations et des
usagers notamment de nos équipements on
a
hérité de vestiaires et aux employés le
terme qui était insalubre c'était
vraiment pas descendre d'accueillir les
clubs sportifs que sont notamment le
football l'athlétisme et d'autres les
scolaires puisque c'est des vestiaires
qui bénéficient au collège au lycée à
nos écoles également donc il fallait
absolument qu'on engage non pas une
réhabilitation pour le coup mais là ça
sera une démolition et reconstruction
pour pouvoir proposer un équipement
sportif de qualité et c'est un petit peu
la même idée qu'on a sur un autre projet
phare qui est celui de la Maison des
arts ou on a une école qui au de
Villepreux a fermé ses portes à la
rentrée scolaire dernière puisque nous
n'avions plus d'écoles de d'élèves
pardon dans le village et pour nous
c'était important de dire que dans ce
village dans ce cœur historique il était
nécessaire d'avoir un projet dynamique
qui permet de porter tout le village
vers le haut et d'entamer justement une
redynamisation de ce village et on peut
pas laisser une école fermée sans avoir
un projet derrière donc ce sera une
maison des arts un pôle culturel à
destination aussi des associations
de ces associations culturelles c'était
une forte demande puisque aujourd'hui je
dirais qu'on a une commune qui en raison
des différents projets immobiliers qui
ont été actés par mes prédécesseurs à
sur le plan démographique qui
urbanistique qui évolue considérablement
en peu de temps c'est à dire qu'en
l'espace de 5 ans on a gagné près de
3000 3500 habitants ça veut dire qu'il y
a une forte demande au nom notamment de
la vie associative pour pouvoir proposer
des activités donc on pousse un peu les
murs on essaye de trouver de la place
pour tout le monde et je rends hommage
aux associations qui font un travail
remarquable et qui sont vraiment dans
cette logique avec nous de trouver des
bonnes solutions et donc cet équipement
en tout cas c'est pas une création
nouvelle on repart d'une école qui est
une ancienne imprimerie du siècle
dernier
tout ce qui fait le charme du bâtiment
tout en apportant un petit peu de
modernité avec un cabinet d'architecte
avec lequel on a déjà travaillé et
l'idée derrière en tout cas je trouve
que c'est un beau symbole justement de
ces projets qui lie aussi réhabilitation
rénovation et performance énergétique et
environnementale dans le sens où on
n'est pas sur la construction nouvelle
donc on va pas venir artificialiser des
sols qui seraient aujourd'hui naturelle
on va requalifier un bâtiment et je
pense que le projet est performé
intéressant puisque on a réussi à
obtenir 2 millions d'euros de
subventions et notamment le bonus
écologique de 500.000 euros par la
Région Île-de-France ce qui montre que
ce projet va dans le bon sens alors
quelles sont les associations qui seront
présentes à la Maison des Arts alors je
disais on est dans l'idée d'optimiser au
maximum de locaux c'est dire que moi je
suis très attaché à dire que les salles
associatives les différents espaces ne
sont pas la propriété d'une association
sont évidemment des bâtiments municipaux
qui ont vocation à être proposés aux
associations mais il faut que tout le
monde arrive à partager l'espace en
fonction des besoins de chacune pour le
coup on peut penser à l'école de musique
puisque évidemment cette Maison des Arts
a vocation à accueillir la musique la
peinture accueillir le chant à
accueillir toutes les arbres dans toutes
leurs formes et c'est vrai que nous
avons aujourd'hui un certain nombre
d'acteurs communaux qui œuvrent dans ces
domaines-là et qui je pense qu'on ravie
d'intégrer ce nouvel équipement et c'est
un peu plus plus loin dans le temps mais
il y a aussi un autre projet en cours
c'est une résidence d'accueil pour les
personnes atteintes de troubles
psychiques qui devraient ouvrir en 2024
alors pourquoi c'était un besoin sur le
territoire c'est un besoin sur le
territoire et c'est la concrétisation
pour nous de notre politique d'inclusion
du handicap c'était la grande cause
municipale à Villepreux sur 2022 en 2023
ce sera pardon l'engagement citoyen et
donc ce projet là qu'on a réussi à
lancer en 2022 il répond à une forte
demande locale mais aussi des
partenaires d'avoir des structures
équipées et adaptées pour des personnes
en situation de handicap notamment
psychique pour pour ce qui concerne la
résidence accueil qui sera avenue des
Clayes-sous-Bois c'est un beau projet
c'est un projet qui permet de proposer
des logements à des personnes qui en ont
besoin et puis pour nous en tout cas
pour les obligations communales c'est
aussi comptabiliser comme du logement
social et comme à Villepreux on est un
petit peu en retard sur ses obligations
là ce qui se traduit d'ailleurs par des
pénalités financière et budgétaire
chaque année on a fait le souhait
d'aller sur ce type de projet parce que
ça va nous permettre d'avancer sur cet
objectif mais on est très fier de ce
projet là on travaille avec un grand
nombre d'acteurs et je crois que c'est
je parlais de solidarité tout à l'heure
c'est un projet qui vient s'inscrire en
tout cas dans cette politique de
solidarité il y aura combien de
logements environ vous le savez déjà une
trentaine de une trentaine de logements
des studios principalement pour pouvoir
loger des résidents qui sont en attente
à l'heure actuelle d'un logement et dans
l'accompagnement il y aura notamment du
personnel qui sera dans cette structure
alors dans vos dans votre discours de
vœux 2023 vous avez aussi parlé
d'engagement citoyen alors concrètement
ça veut dire quoi ça va passer par quoi
vous savez alors il y a tout type
d'engagement aujourd'hui que ce soit
l'engagement politique l'engagement
associatif moi je sais pas si on
traverse aujourd'hui une crise de
l'engagement ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il
y a une mutation de l'engagement et
qu'on s'engage plus de la même façon
aujourd'hui qu'auparavant je prends un
exemple tout simple sur le bénévolat
associatif on voit on a du mal à
renouveler le personnel de bénévoles
associatif notamment sur les postes à
responsabilités sur les fonctions de
bureau les trésoriers etc les présidents
d'assaut donc notre idée c'est de
pouvoir à la fois via une plateforme
d'ailleurs qu'on a créé et qu'on a
poussé faire un match entre les demandes
des associations leurs besoins et puis
tous ces villes prosiens qui ne
demandent qu'à s'engagées parce que je
pense que autour de la table on croise
tous les jours des personnes qui disent
et j'aimerais m'engager là où je pense
que l'engagement a un petit peu muté
c'est que les personnes avec leur vie
professionnelle leur vie familiale ne
sont plus prêtes et disposer à s'engager
de façon on va dire lourde et pérenne au
sein d'une même structure tout au long
d'une année et donc l'idée pour nous
c'est de favoriser l'engagement sous
toutes ses formes notamment chez les
jeunes on a un super dispositif de
l'État qui est le service national
universel et on a la chance de
travailler à ce dispositif avec le lycée
avec évidemment le l'éducation nationale
et on a envie de faire vivre ça on a
pour ambition aussi de créer à
Villepreux un conseil municipal junior
donc voilà on veut faire vivre
l'engagement citoyen sous toutes ses
formes je pense aussi aux échos délégués
qui sont dans une logique aussi de
promouvoir et bien la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et on se rend
compte qu'il y a énormément de force au
sein de la commune qui veulent s'engager
parfois faut juste aider à déclencher
l'étincelle et donc c'est la mission
qu'on s'est donné pour 2023 merci
Jean-Baptiste amonique juste avant de
terminer cet entretien c'est l'interview
express
[Musique]
alors le principe c'est 5 questions
courtes et cinq réponses assez courtes
vous pourrez répondre oui ou non ou pour
ou contre pour certaines des questions
pour d'autres pour d'autres vous pouvez
me répondre en 20 secondes mais vraiment
maximum est-ce que vous êtes prêts c'est
bon je suis prêt augmentez-vous les
impôts locaux dans votre commune en 2023
en 203 non
pour ou contre la circulation à 30 km/h
dans la ville pour essayer de
l'obligation du bio dans les cantines
alors je suis pas je suis pas contre
l'obligation du bio en revanche nous on
est très performant sur le bio puisque
avant même l'adoption de la loi egalim
on avait plus de 50% de produits bio on
favorise les circuits courts on vient
d'ailleurs d'installer enfin
d'introduire des pommes d'un producteur
local donc circuit court et bio moi je
suis pour à 100% après les obligations
généralement je suis pas forcément pour
mais en tout cas nous on le fait pour
dans l'exercice de vos fonctions
avez-vous déjà eu peur physiquement non
et pour finir est-ce que vous êtes un
maire heureux aujourd'hui je suis un
maire heureux comblé passionné fatigué
mais déterminé et motivé et bien merci
beaucoup Jean-Baptiste ammonique d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je le rappelle
vous êtes le maire de Villepreux on en
parlait en début d'émission la semaine
dernière le lycée franco-allemand de Buc
célébré les 60 ans du traité de l'Elysée
ce traité la réconciliation entre la
France et l'Allemagne après plusieurs
décennies de conflits Marie-Alix Morlet
vous êtes la proviseur du lycée
franco-allemand de Buc ce traité les
signer le 22 janvier
1963 et 60 ans après 1000 élèves en
célébré ce pacte d'amitié entre
l'Allemagne et la France alors c'est un
moment attendu dans le lycée oui alors
nous avons travaillé depuis la rentrée
de septembre sur ce projet donc nous
avions le temps fort donc vous parlez
mardi dernier mais également toute une
semaine franco-allemande afin de
permettre à l'ensemble de notre
communauté scolaire de vivre cet
événement donc nous accueillons en effet
cette année plus de 1070 élèves qui ont
tous participé à cet événement de mardi
après-midi ce sont je le rappelle des
élèves du CP à la Terminale puisque le
lycée franco-allemand est une cité
scolaire entièrement public et nous
avions donc
répartis la semaine avec un programme
dévast pour revenir sur cet après-midi
de mardi dernier le but était non
seulement qu'il y ait un temps commun
avec les mille élèves réunis dans
l'atrium de l'établissement autour des
traditionnels discours mais aussi des
hymnes français européen allemand et
l'hymne du LFA puisque nous avons notre
propre notre propre musique et ensuite
de permettre à tous les élèves de
partager leurs compétences avec
différents ateliers je pense que vous
voudrez revenir sur
le but étant nous avions donc trois
rotations qui permettaient à tous les
élèves d'assister à un concert de
participer à un parcours artistique et
culturel et de visionner les vidéos de
notre concours inter-léfa puisque je
rappelle que les autres lycées
franco-allemand historiques sont à
Fribourg et à Sarrebruck en Allemagne et
les deux petits derniers ont ouvert à
Hambourg à la rentrée 2020 et à
Strasbourg la rentrée 2021 alors quand
est-ce qu'il a été créé ce lycée c'est
grâce à ce traité de très peu de temps
après le traité de l'Elysée a lieu un
accord intergouvernemental qui va fonder
la création des lycées franco-allemand
donc en ce qui concerne but nous notre
naissance remonte à 1975 et la structure
à partir de là ne va cesser d'évoluer
puisque partie du niveau lycée on
redescend ensuite sur le collège
quelques années après va voir nous
allons voir l'ouverture d'une école
allemande qui est devenue
franco-allemande il y a deux ans et nous
avons également notre sein une section
internationale britannique de la seconde
à la terminale qui est importante
souligner puisque lors de ces temps
forts nous nous avons à cœur d'intégrer
l'ensemble des élèves de la structure
afin qu'il puisse être dans cette
mouvance et dans cette histoire
franco-allemande mais surtout mieux se
connaître les uns les autres
l'amitié franco-allemande ça vous parle
autour du plateau Jean-Baptiste
harmonique
j'ai fait classe européenne allemande
alors je n'engageons pas une
conversation c'est pas comme le vélo ça
s'oublie mais puis je suis je suis
européen et vous savez à Villepreux on a
les commémoration du 8 mai mais on a à
cœur de célébrer aussi la Journée de
l'Europe et donc le 9 mai on propose
constamment quelque chose et l'auda la
joie en tout cas l'Union Européen est un
nime qui me qui me touche très
particulièrement donc félicitations et
bravo pour vos actions
et pas de classe européenne mais par
contre effectivement je trouve ça
intéressant de proposer ça aux élèves ça
se fait de plus en plus c'est une
ouverture de manière générale donc c'est
important
je suis originaire de Moselle donc
proche de l'Allemagne donc forcément
habitué dans mon enfance dans mon
parcours scolaire avec des liens
effectivement assez étroits entre la
France et l'Allemagne on va revenir un
petit peu au programme de cette semaine
pour célébrer les 60 ans du traité vous
avez parlé de deux concerts est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire un petit peu
plus oui alors nous avions différents
avec notamment des conférences une
conférence d'un auteur allemand hands
sous le richtraichel qui est au
programme du baccalauréat pour nos
élèves puisque je le rappelle nos élèves
passe le baccalauréat franco-allemand
qui est un diplôme spécifique donc nous
avons eu la chance d'accueillir monsieur
trail jeudi dernier nous avions
également une conférence plus historique
vraiment sur la création
oui la de ce traité de l'Elysée et sur
ses conséquences immédiates donc il y a
eu lieu vendredi après-midi grâce au
à l'Institut histoire allemande
nous avions à côté de ça des moments un
peu plus un peu plus partagés comme
l'intervention d'Arte avec Claire
doutrio qui nous a fait l'honneur de
venir animer et expliquer aux élèves
comment fonctionnent les missions
carambolage donc c'était le mardi matin
et puis des temps purement festifs
puisque nous avons des élèves qui ne qui
regorgent d'imagination donc nous avons
eu la chance de tourner un
vendredi matin donc trois heures de
tournage avec les 1000 élèves de la
structure à l'initiative donc de notre
Conseil de Vie Lycéenne donc tout a été
pris en charge par les élèves de
terminale voilà donc ça a été un grand
moment et nous attendons le résultat
avec beaucoup d'impatience et évidemment
c'est ajouter ce week-end puisque nos
portes ouvertes étaient
expressément placé ce samedi 21 janvier
afin d'accueillir les familles pour de
nos futurs élèves pour les examens
d'entrée et pour la rentrée prochaine
nous avions également un partenariat
avec la ville de Buc pour le concert de
Fire patch qui est un groupe de hip-hop
franco-allemand qui a eu lieu samedi
soir et puis dimanche grande cérémonie
officielle entre le président Emmanuel
Macron et le chancelier OLAP scholls à
laquelle nous avons eu la chance
d'assister et bien merci beaucoup
Marie-Alix Marley d'être venue en parler
avec tout je vous rappelle vous êtes
proviseur du lycée franco-allemand de
Buc c'est là maintenant de passer à
notre page loisirs
et on démarre cette partie loisirs en
partant à la direction de Versailles un
bouillon vient d'ouvrir ses portes juste
à côté du château le restaurant propose
des plats traditionnels à des prix très
bas l'établissement affiche complet midi
et soir depuis son ouverture en décembre
mais Mickaël elle met Deo et Patrick
Jacques de dispute ont réussi à trouver
une classe et ont pu le tester regardez
[Musique]
c'est le restaurant dont tout le monde
parle ici à Versailles le petit bouillon
vient d'ouvrir ici dans la cité royale
il est tout juste midi et il y a déjà
beaucoup de monde qui attend pour entrer
à l'intérieur
[Musique]
la salle est remplie dès l'ouverture et
si on retrouve des clients venus des
environs mais également des touristes on
a visité le château de Versailles et
donc c'était l'occasion de venir sur sur
un restaurant on avait entendu parler
des bouillons ouais du principe de
bouillon et on connaissait pas donc
comme il y avait un là on est venu là
tout simplement c'est le bouche à
oreille tout simplement
et moi je suis déjà venue je trouve ça
très bien les prix rapport qualité-prix
c'est excellent le restaurant ouvert le
16 décembre dernier réalise aujourd'hui
plus de 25 couvert par service le
directeur a dû embaucher 30 personnes
pour répondre à la demande toujours
croissante
[Musique]
nous avons rien inventé puisque c'est en
1855 que Pierre-Louis Duval avait créé
le premier bouillon dans les halles où
il faisait manger les ouvriers des
Halles en 1900 les choses se sont
vraiment démocratisées et en
l'occurrence il y avait à peu près 250
bouillons sur la capitale on retrouve
tous les plats à l'ancienne on va
commencer par les entrées l’œuf mimosa
l'os à moelle la terrine du chef qui est
une terrine à l'ancienne après vous
allez passer sur les plats traditionnels
qui sont la blanquette de veau le bœuf
bourguignon
[Musique]
de mon côté ce midi j'ai commandé une
fondue de fromage au miel à 3,40 une
blanquette de veau à 12,50 € et une
mousse au chocolat en dessert à 3,50 €
prix total 19,40 sans boissons à la fin
du service c'est l'heure du bilan pour
les clients
[Musique]
même dans le centre de Versailles vous
avez pas des prix comme ça très bien
franchement alors moi ce que j'avais
c'était comme Madame un poulet avec les
endives tout était parfait brigé comme
il faut ça correspond tout à fait à nos
attentes on va très bien manger
que dire les places sont très bons pas
dû manger sans compter les boissons
grosso modo pas pour 20 euros par
personne c'est quand même relativement
correct avec un service quand même très
agréable des gens très sympathiques il
est 14h c'est la fin du service ici au
bouillon de Versailles comme vous pouvez
le voir il y a beaucoup moins de monde
ici si vous voulez venir déguster le
restaurant est ouvert à tous les jours
sauf le lundi à bon appétit
et nous avons été rejoint en plateau par
Anthony Marie bonsoir alors vous allez
parler vous allez nous parler dans
quelques instants de la Thoiry night
race et puis par Grégory canalet
journaliste de la rédaction bonsoir vous
prenez le relais de Nicolas dandry ce
soir vous faites le quiz
pour moi que de prendre son relais et on
va jouer ce soir avec 50 ans en Yvelines
puisque ce sont ce soir les vœux de
l'agglomération donc on apprend un peu
plus sur l'histoire de l'agglomération
mais alors juste avant je voulais vous
faire réagir sur le reportage qu'on
vient de voir est-ce que ça vous donne
envie de le tester en plateau
bah ça permet ça donne faim déjà
tout ce qu'il faut pour voilà c'est
rajouter à la toux de liste
des restaurateurs testés je rejoins que
l'horaire est bien quand même
effectivement à se donner envie d'y
aller effectivement trouver un
restaurant avec une gastronomie
française comme ça et avec un rapport
qualité prix de cette qualité j'ai envie
de dire il faut se trouver ça se tente
et bien on va parler musique à présent
maintenant célébrer les arts et la
culture le temps d'une soirée c'est
l'objectif de la nuit des conservatoires
un événement national qui aura lieu
demain soir et le conservatoire de
Maurepas y participe pour en parler avec
nous Julien Pauly vous êtes le directeur
du conservatoire de Maurepas alors on a
parlé rapidement du programme de demain
soir au Conservatoire vous avez choisi
le thème du Japon cette année au niveau
musical pourquoi alors c'est un thème
qui a été choisi par les professeurs du
conservatoire de façon collégiale mais
complètement arbitraire c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait l'événement de la nuit des
conservatoires est un événement national
qui se décline au niveau local donc le
conservatoire de Maurepas est emparé
voilà de cette opportunité pour faire
une soirée musical et on a effectivement
décidé de faire une partie de cette
soirée pas l'intégralité mais une partie
sur le thème du Japon donc avec des
musiques traditionnelles japonaises avec
des musiques d'animés japonais voilà des
grands films qu'on devrait réalisateur
qu'on connaît bien voilà donc une partie
sur le Japon mais pas seulement et donc
il y aura aussi une partie théâtre avec
de la comédie musicale Thésée et le
Minotaure ce sera par des élèves de
primaires est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire quelques mots oui alors
effectivement sur l'intégralité de la
soirée il y a plusieurs événements qui
s'enchaînent plusieurs formes musicales
et théâtrales une partie effectivement
concernée concerne effectivement le
Minotaure qui est un conte musical qui
sera donné par l'école élémentaire
d'effriches alors le lien avec le
Conservatoire c'est que tout simplement
que le conservatoire a des missions
d'éducation artistique et culturelle et
on a deux professeurs du conservatoire
qui interviennent en milieu scolaire
tout au long de l'année pour aider les
classes et les professeurs des écoles à
monter le projet musicaux donc c'était
aussi pour valoriser ce travail qui
réalisait au sein des écoles en plus du
reste de la soirée qui est consacré
proprement aux élèves qui sont inscrits
au Conservatoire que ce soit des
musiciens ou des comédiens puisque le
conservatoire est à conservatoire de
musique et d'art dramatique donc on va
avoir de la musique un peu de contes de
musique est-ce qu'il y aura de la danse
ou pas alors pas de danse chez nous
parce que le conservateur dispose on
dispense uniquement des cours de musique
et de théâtre mais voilà différentes
formes musicales des concerts avec une
diversité de discipline qui seront
représentés ça va du piano solo aux
orchestres sous une voilà une soirée qui
comme je vous le disais débute à 18h
pour s'achever à minuit avec voilà on
invite vraiment les gens à venir passer
autant de temps qu'il le souhaite les
portes sont ouvertes l'accès est libre
on a aussi une formule de restauration
sur place qui permet aux gens vraiment
de profiter de l'intégralité de la
soirée de piocher de venir quand ils
veulent de repartir quand ils veulent
pour profiter un maximum de voilà
découvrir ce qu'on fait au Conservatoire
à travers ces prestations musicales et
théâtrales c'est de de faire découvrir
le conservatoire et de rendre la musique
accessible à tous oui complètement à
l'origine quand cet événement national a
été créé c'est la 10e édition cette
année donc il y a 10 ans l'objectif
était vraiment de faire découvrir ce qui
se passe dans les conservatoires de
valoriser le la qualité de
l'enseignement qui est dispensé de
montrer aussi la diversité des profils
des élèves puisqu'on a des enfants des
adolescents des adultes on prend les
enfants à partir de 4 ans par exemple au
conservatoire de Maurepas une autre
doyen doit fêter peut-être les 90 ans
cette année donc vraiment une diversité
de de profil de personnes qui pratiquent
qui pratiquent la musique et l'art
dramatique et l'idée c'est de montrer
cette diversité là les ensembles les
orchestres les pièces de théâtre qu'on
peut voilà qu'on peut créer à travers
l'inscription au conservatoire
ou est-ce que si on n'a pas eu
d'éducation musicale étant adulte on
peut aussi
on a déjà d'huile qui débutent euh
complètement la musique on a beaucoup
aussi de personnes qui arrivaient à un
âge où elles ont un peu plus de temps
personnel disponibles reprennent une
pratique musicale qu'elles avaient par
le passé et puis voilà soit au moment de
la retraite soit quand les enfants sont
partis de la maison
reviennent s'inscrire dans un
conservatoire pour pratiquer la musique
soit reprendre des cours d'instruments
soit simplement intégrer ce qu'on
appelle les pratiques collectives donc
les orchestres les ensembles pour voilà
pour jouer avec d'autres partager des
moments musicaux on a vraiment tous les
profils et des adultes y compris est-ce
que vous avez des élèves qui en ont fait
leur métier aujourd'hui oui bien sûr
quelques-uns c'est évidemment une
minorité puisque le le l'objectif
principal du Conservatoire c'est de
former surtout des musiciens amateurs et
des amateurs éclairés et qui puissent
avoir une pratique autonome ensuite
quand il quitte au Conservatoire mais
certains ont poussé vraiment plus loin
leur pratique et sont aujourd'hui
professeurs dans des conservatoires ou
musiciens interprètent de très haut
niveau voilà il y a plusieurs musiciens
qui effectivement son professionnel
aujourd'hui et donc le Conservatoire
c'est aussi un moyen pour pour ceux qui
n'ont peut-être pas l'accès à la culture
de d'avoir ce premier accès or hors
école et hors-parents effectivement
alors ça c'est évidemment une pratique
de loisirs certains enfants même
découvrent aussi la musique à travers
les projets scolaires l'intervention des
musiciens d'intervenants en milieu
scolaire dont je vous parlais qui
parfois est une clé d'entrée aussi
musicale qui leur qui suscite un intérêt
un appétit pour la musique et après avec
le désir de s'inscrire au conservatoire
pour avoir une pratique un peu plus
soutenue assidue c'est une pratique de
loisir on a certains élèves qui viennent
là et qui passent une année deux années
trois années au conservatoire et qui
voilà s'inscrit dans une démarche de
découverte de sensibilisation musicale
et certains qui s'inscrivent sur un plus
long terme jusqu'à voilà comme je vous
le disais un aspect presque prêt
professionnel ou professionnel pour
certains
justement vous parliez des enfants vous
arrivez à les intéresser aux
conservatoire ils peuvent je sais pas y
avoir envie d'autre chose de sport par
exemple comment vous arrivez à les à les
concentrer là-dedans
de plus en plus qui pratiquent
énormément d'activités que ce soit
culturel donc du Conservatoire musical
ou sport on a et on a au sein du
Conservatoire des enfants qui font plein
d'activités de loisirs on a certains qui
ne font que de la musique ou du théâtre
on les intéresse parce que ce qui
viennent chercher je pense il le trouve
à travers ce que les professeurs leur
proposent on a des professeurs qui sont
vraiment qualifiés expérimentés et qui
ont qui ont aussi le goût de la
transmission et de ce qu'ils font et
donc voilà je c'est grâce à ce travail
là aussi qu'on continue à motiver les
élèves et à monter aussi des projets de
qualité dont ceux qui seront présentés
sur la nuit des conservatoire et puis on
parlait d'ouverture d'esprit tout à
l'heure au travers des relations
franco-allemand de la musique c'est
aussi un exutoire ça permet de se
échapper entre guillemets aussi oui
effectivement et surtout par les par les
temps qui courent ou c'est vraiment
voilà peut-être quelque chose qui est un
peu à part on prend le temps de se
déconnecter de de la vie du quotidien et
puis de d'être vraiment dans une bulle
artistique musicale théâtre et puis de
partager avec d'autres parce que c'est
vraiment ça aussi l'intérêt c'est de
pouvoir faire de la musique ou faire du
théâtre avec d'autres personnes et de
présenter ça aussi et ben aux familles
aux amis qui viennent voir les la
réalisation des concerts et des
spectacles et bien merci Julien Pauly
d'être venu en parler un plateau avec
nous si vous êtes intéressé par la nuit
des conservatoires rendez-vous demain à
partir de 18h jusqu'à minuit à l'espace
Albert Camus de Maurepas l'entrée est
libre dans la limite des places
disponibles un autre rendez-vous à ne
pas manquer ce week-end c'est là à
Thoiry night race il s'agit d'une
première édition le principe qu'une
course nocturne de 1 km à 10 km au cœur
du parc zoologique de Thoiry et des
lumières sauvages pour en parler Anthony
Marie vous êtes responsable
l'événementiel aux réseaux safari de
Thoiry alors après trois éditions de la
soirée wild race vous avez décidé de
détourner cette course en édition
nocturne pourquoi ce choix alors très
simplement puisque nous avons depuis 5
ans maintenant les lumières sauvages sur
zoo safari ça rencontre un franc succès
auprès de nos visiteurs puisque
maintenant l'hiver on fait jusqu'à
200000 visiteurs supplémentaires à notre
activité habituelle donc on s'est dit
bien on a un cadre exceptionnel pour
faire une course donc on l'a fait avec
la Thoiry weight race maintenant on va
faire nos visiteurs en plus une arrivée
spectaculaire donc en émettant dans les
lumières tout simplement donc attention
les lumières c'est pas surtout le
parcours il va falloir vraiment avancer
dans la nuit
la petite lampe je vous en apporter un
exemplaire je vous l'offrir avec grand
plaisir si vous souhaitez et
particulièrement performante d'ailleurs
effectivement il y a des zones qui sont
totalement sombres ils vont aller dans
des endroits où pour la plupart des
coureurs et tout à l'heure vous en
receviez
quand même on est quand même pas sur du
performeur il y a quelques performeurs
on va dire que le peloton des 50
premiers ce sont des coureurs émérite
ensuite l'intérêt c'est vraiment d'être
sur une course familiale
où il y a quand même un classement à la
fin avec des récompenses évidemment on
fait un classement c'est normal alors
vous avez déjà un cadeau qui est la
médaille de fin de course donc qui est
un modèle différent chaque année bien
sûr et puis celle-ci c'est l'édition
numéro 1 à 13 je l'offrirai aussi si
vous voulez
vous égaré vous avez effectivement donc
et puis après il y a le classement pour
les vainqueurs de chaque étape donc bien
sûr dans le quatrième enfant car son
fils ensuite dans la 5 km femme homme et
ensuite dans la 10 km femme homme
également donc il y a effectivement des
Trophées des trophées qui viennent en
complément alors vous attendez combien
coureur environ écouter les inscriptions
ça va être ce soir et on est à plus de
1700 coureurs pour cette première
édition donc je pense qu'il va falloir
commencer à inscrire dans dans le temps
cette course nouvelle qui risque d'être
dansante
ce soir à minuit
et si vous n'arrivez pas à vous inscrire
ce soir vous en voyez un petit mail et
puis on arrive à faire quelque chose
demain matin alors une partie des
bénéfices sera pour la sauvegarde des
animaux ça c'est primordial l'activité
événementielle que nous développons
depuis plusieurs années maintenant sur
le saut safari ne peut pas être dissocié
de l'activité principale de notre métier
qui est la préservation des espèces donc
on a à coeur que nous événements Ali
notre travail dans le zoo à au travail
réalisé sur les terrains et donc nous
avons l'association Thoiry conservation
qui est indépendante de Safari qui va
donc percevoir une partie effectivement
de la quote-part des dossards de manière
à ce que ensuite cette agence soit
réinvesti dans des dans des associations
qui protège animal sauvage dans le
milieu naturel ça vous tente la
touaregnate race autour du plateau
mais oui pourquoi pas
qu'on doit faire une courte tous
ensemble mais je pense que c'est
peut-être un peu tard mais quoique à
minuit mais on fait des équipes s'il y a
besoin on peut faire les équipes il y a
pas de souci
[Musique]
et chose importante on peut également
rajouter que la course on peut la faire
déguiser il y a pas de souci
de course à pied j'en faisais beaucoup
effectivement c'est j'aime bien les
courses c'est un peu décalé comme ça un
peu original
c'est totalement décalé et surtout ce
qui nous conforte dans l'idée de
continuer à faire des épreuves sportives
dans le zoo c'est le remerciement de la
part des coureurs et de leur famille
parce qu'effectivement en plus de la
course elle-même je pensais que le
coureur est plutôt un solitaire dans son
dans son sport là pour le coup il est il
est hué ou plutôt il est soutenu pardon
pour certains
leur famille et leurs amis donc c'est
plutôt un moment sympathique de partage
vrai et bien merci Anthony Marly c'était
notre invitation si vous êtes intéressé
vous pouvez toujours vous inscrire du
coup sur le site internet qui s'affiche
juste en bas de votre écran Thoiry point
net le tarif et de 35 euros pour les 10
km 28 euros pour les 5 km et 25 euros
pour celles d'environ 1 km voilà et du
coup si vous ne savez pas quoi faire si
vous n'êtes pas trop adepte de course à
pied il y a toujours les idées de sortie
de Gabriel Gonthier qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous nous avez prévu on
commence par quoi Gabriel et bien on
commence en musique Mathilde avec un
concert de rock Deep Purple et Led
Zeppelin célébration proposé par le
groupe Legacy 7.0 au programme un
concert de rock progressif le groupe
reprendra des titres emblématiques du
répertoire des mythiques Deep Purple et
Led Zeppelin 1h30 de show programme vu
par le groupe comme un moment de partage
et d'échange avec le public je vous
propose qu'on écoute un extrait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
demain à 21h au smile World bowling à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux alors on change
un peu de registre Gabriel mais toujours
en musique avec un karaoké au
Mesnil-Saint-Denis oui un karaoké même
si vous aimez chanter rendez-vous
vendredi à partir de 19h dans la salle
de spectacle de la barrière de la
verrière pardon alors le principe il est
simple une liste de chansons et les
paroles qui défilent mais là c'est un
vrai concert qui vous est proposé avec
scène musicien jeux de lumière et
publique et j'ai été consulté la liste
des titres pour vous il y aura de la
variété française Louane M Pokora en
passant par Florent Pagny ou encore
Jean-Jacques Goldman mais également des
chansons internationales comme YouTube
Adèle Queen ou encore oasis alors je
sais pas si vous êtes des adeptes des
karaoké si ça vous tente ou pas je suis
un peu timide moi j'aime pas trop
chanter de devant les autres devant avec
un micro mais pourquoi
Anthony Marie
ouais moi je suis plus spectateur aussi
et donc on poursuit vos idées de sortie
Gabriel avec une pièce de théâtre à ne
pas manquer au théâtre Coluche de
plaisir mais le spectacle incandescence
se met en scène des jeunes nés de
parents ayant vécu l'exil et résidents
dans des quartiers populaires au-delà du
théâtre ce sont de vrais témoignages qui
sont racontés au total une centaine de
jeunes ont accepté de rencontrer Ahmed
Madani pour raconter leur histoire neuve
d'entre eux seront sur scène ce
spectacle c'est le troisième volet de la
trilogie face à leur destin imaginé par
Ahmed Madani les jeux des acteurs le les
jeux des acteurs pardon à
particulièrement été salués par la
critique et les médias je pense
notamment au journal La Croix qui salue
notamment le talent des comédiens qui
habitent la scène avec une énergie sans
pareil et alors vous nous proposez aussi
une exposition qui s'achève bientôt
Gabriel oui c'est le dernier week-end
pour profiter de l'exposition ciao
Italia alors l'espace Maurice Béjart de
Verneuil-sur-Seine mais l'Italie à
l'honneur au travers de l'exposition
c'est 100 ans génération italienne en
France qui sont racontées une histoire
importante dans la seconde moitié du 19e
siècle jusque dans les années 1960 les
Italiens étaient les étrangers les plus
nombreux dans l'Hexagone ils sont venus
en grande partie pour l'emploi
l'exposition elle revient sur
l'intégration parfois difficile mais
aussi l'apport des Italiens à la société
française cette exposition a été prêtée
par le musée de l'histoire de
l'immigration je pense que ça peut vous
intéresser Grégory
descendant de l'immigration était de
voilà fils petit-fils même d'immigré
italien donc forcément cette exposition
dernier week-end pour cette exposition
c'est jusqu'au 29 janvier un autre
rendez-vous insolite est à découvrir
samedi à Guyancourt oui un rendez-vous
insolite et surtout un bon plan pour les
amateurs de jeux la société Asmodée donc
il y a un leader international
spécialisé dans les jeux de société et
qui est basé à Guyancourt organise une
grande braderie devant ses locaux vous y
trouverez de nombreux jeux à prix réduit
et surtout les gains seront reversés à
l'association solidaire Bou on termine
avec légèreté et humour vous nous
proposez du stand-up dimanche prochain
oui humoriste et acteur français Jim au
Salim qui a notamment joué dans les
méchants IMA ou encore loin du périph
avec Omar Sy foulera la scène de la
Merise de Trappes c'est dimanche à 16h
pour un spectacle de stand-up alors vous
y retrouverez sa lenteur
caractéristiques dans sa façon de
s'exprimer devenu aujourd'hui ça marque
de fabrique merci beaucoup Gabriel
Gonthier alors bon comme d'habitude
petit tour de plateau est-ce que il y a
une idée de sortie qui est que vous avez
préférée l'exposition ciao Talia
juste avant pour se mettre dans de
bonnes conditions on va finir en humour
le weekend voilà un week-end très
complet
je suis assez fan j'aime beaucoup ce
qu'il fait
et maintenant on va c'est l'heure du
quiz Grégory canalet dans votre site
alors vous remplacez Nicolas dandry j'ai
déjà dit et c'est notamment à l'occasion
des vœux de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines là
vous nous proposez un quiz sur
l'histoire de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
alors tout à l'heure nous étions à la
cérémonie des vœux de 50 ans en Yvelines
on va justement commencer avec une
cérémonie des vœux nous sommes en 1999
et le SAN qui est le syndicat
d'agglomération nouvelle on ne parle pas
encore de communauté d'agglomération
réunit alors les habitants des sept
communes de 50 ans en Yvelines plusieurs
personnes s'expriment dans ce reportage
je vous laisse regarder moment
traditionnel d'annonce des grandes
nouveautés pour l'année à venir les vœux
du SAN nous ont permis de recueillir les
projets de vos mères d'annoncer ce soir
que nous relancions l'aménagement
l'étude de l'aménagement de la colline
de la revanche pour en faire une station
de sports d'hiver de ski c'est la mise
au point d'une convention avec la ville
de Montigny-le-Bretonneux pour
construire une piscine intercommunale il
y a toute une démarche d'équipement il y
a aussi cette démarche de cohérence et
de projet de ville qui mériterait d'être
soutenu et j'espère que ça pourra l'être
c'est la vidéo surveillance la vidéo
surveillance est un élément simplement
de sécurité pour les habitants plein de
choses essentielles il y a la
reconduction du contrat de ville c'est
quelque chose tout à fait fondamental
pour nous mais c'est vrai que les bons
résultats déjà font qu'on va discuter de
ça en quelques jours de voir un peu les
arbitrages premier le plus important le
plus attendu c'est la réhabilitation du
pont du routoir qui va enfin démarrer y
compris le centre commercial
de la mort de Jean Racine et là
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui va
se réaliser sur à peu près 6-7 mois
alors la question sur cette thématique
qui sont ces personnes alors déjà
quelles fonctions elles occupent ça a
été dit dans le reportage
des mères des présidents de
l'agglomération de 50 ans Nîmes
qui sont exprimées et le président de
l'agglomération de 50 ans en ligne à
l'époque on disait le SAN on disait
syndicats d'agglomération nouvelle
est-ce que vous en avez reconnu parmi
ces personnes les invités peuvent jouer
aussi
en tout cas vous êtes déjà un bon point
un point également pour Gabriel qui a
reconnu Jean-Michel faugos c'est tout
non
le président actuel président du conseil
départemental on va regarder tout de
suite les réponses les différents élus
alors il y avait Robert Cadalbert le
président de l'époque de San un
agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
Alexis bet maire de voisins de gros
tonneux il y avait également Jacques
monco qu'on va voir dans un instant lui
a été le dernier maire communiste de
Trappes entre 96 et 2001 disparu en 2014
on a vu également Nicolas Abou maire de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et qui a été
également sénateur des Yvelines pierre
Sélincourt dernier mère communiste non
avant dernier maire communiste de la
verrière pendant même avant dernier il y
en a eu deux autres après il y a
également Jean-Michel fourgouse qui est
l'actuel président de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines mère
d'Élancourt là vous aviez
petit indice regardez juste derrière
c'est Roland Nadeau qui était maire de
Guyancourt entre 83 et 2002 et enfin
Jacques loliose l'ancien maire de Mani
léamo il a effectué deux mandats à la
tête de la commune merci socialiste
voilà
je crois que Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
qui est là depuis nombreuses années ici
les avait tous donc c'est vrai que
c'était plus une question pour lui on
aurait pu lui poser sur sur ce plateau
regardez cette image à présent qui va
s'afficher où est-ce que c'est à votre
avis alors bon à l'image un petit peu si
on peut la remettre peut-être en régie
la relancer parce que là du coup vous ne
voyez pas forcément
l'entrée de
là où est maintenant est situé
skywestiment on n'est pas loin du
théâtre de 50 ans et demi est-ce qu'on
peut la revoir
alors bon on va voir la réponse
s'affiche en images peut-être une idée
vous n'êtes pas du tout 50 ans en
Yvelines Gabriel
bon en tout cas vous avez raison on est
bien à Montigny-le-Bretonneux et ce lieu
on va regarder la réponse en images
s'appelle le parvis des sources l'image
date de 1991 on va peut-être voir la
l'animation s'afficher et on est à
l'époque de la construction de l'église
de Saint-Quentin les sources
l'architecte c'est Michel oeuvre qui
l'on doit aussi de nombreuses
réalisations à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
et vous ne voyez pas il y a pas de
d'image vous ne voyez pas encore les
bâtiments d'habitation autour à ceux qui
accueillaient ce qui accueille notamment
aujourd'hui le conservatoire des armes
municipales des arts plastiques
conservateurs municipal des arts
plastiques et le pôle jeunesse de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux c'est beaucoup
plus difficile sans les images allez
dire mais en tout cas oui maintenant il
y a des restaurants il y a le pot de
jeunesse qui sont sur ce parvis des
sources qui est très reconnaissant avec
son bassin caractéristique avec des
petits signes géométriques qui font
penser impossible de de d'une célèbre de
célèbre marque de console de jeux vidéo
voilà je dirais pas plus vous avez une
troisième question pour nous Grégory
bien sûr alors regardez également ces
images pendant nombreuses années on sait
que 50 ans en Yvelines a été en
perpétuelle chantier et je vous emmène
sur un chantier d'un site emblématique
du territoire nous sommes dans les
années 1990 c'est le chantier de quel
site à votre avis on va peut-être avoir
quelqu'un voilà vous avez un petit
indice et le plan de cette énorme
structure présente à 50 ans en Yvelines
alors là on parle d'un site industriel
d'une marque automobile voilà pour vous
donner un petit indice
[Musique]
de Renault alors quel site de Renault le
Technocentre tout à fait bien jouer
Mathilde Technocentre Renault
la réponse s'afficher qui est le centre
de recherche de la marque au losange le
1er centre de R&D en Europe il a été
inauguré en 1998 et il est implanté
partiellement sur les anciennes pistes
de l'aérodrome Caudron encore
aujourd'hui à 11000 salariés sont
présents sur site ils sont installés sur
150 hectares de terrain ce qui pourrait
évoluer à l'avenir puisque Renault est
engagé dans un projet d'économie Renault
va vendre environ 25 hectares de ce site
à la Société du Grand Paris puisque non
loin passera la ligne 18 à l'horizon
2030 ligne 18 du métro merci beaucoup
ce soir
difficile que les écrivains la semaine
dernière j'ai envie de dire quand même
les écrivains la semaine dernière et
c'était compliqué je remercie Nicolas
pour tous ces bons conseils j'espère
pouvoir lui succéder à l'avenir sur sur
ces quiz est-ce que je vous repose la
question est-ce que vous avez envie de
savoir la météo de demain et de ce
weekend
bien sûr
on va regarder la météo de demain tout
de suite
[Musique]
demain matin le ciel sera nuageux sur
l'ensemble des Yvelines au niveau des
températures il fera froid compter 4
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie 3 à Houdan et
Versailles et deux à Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi le ciel sera toujours
couvert au niveau des températures
comptées 3 à 2 degrés en moyenne et
alors pour ce week-end quel temps
fera-t-il Gabriel les températures
restent fraîches Mathilde ce weekend
comptez 2 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie
Versailles et Houdan et 1 degré du côté
de Rambouillet côté ciel le temps est
nuageux toute la matinée l'après midi
elle sera plus ensoleillée avec des
températures comprises entre 3 et 4
degrés dimanche la tendance reste la
même comptez 0° à Versailles et
Rambouillet du côté de Mantes-la-Jolie
et Houdan il fera 1 degré dimanche
après-midi le ciel se couvre et les
températures seront comprises entre deux
et quatre degrés il faudra se couvrir ce
week-end merci beaucoup Gabriel et bah
c'est déjà la fin de cette émission
merci pour votre fidélité je vous
souhaite une belle soirée sur TV 78
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]